>> THEY ACTUALLY TALK TO ME
ABOUT IT FOR THEY THOUGHT IT WA
FUNNY.
HEY THERE, HAPPY FRIDAY MY
FRIDAY FRIENDS.
WHAT IS UP WITH DON'T WORRY, I'
GOING TO BE FAIR TO HIM.
BUT THE DISGRACED FORMER SKIES
BUCKET DIRT BAG WILL SPEND FOUR
YEARS IN JAILBIRD THAT'S ONE FO
EVERY FOLLICLE.
THE REASON IS STEALING $300,000
FROM STARS TRIP OR, THE NEXT
MISSUS GILL GIL MEAD, STORMY
DANIELS.
I'M GETTING.
THAT RELATIONSHIP WOULD NEVER
WORK WITH HER BOOK OUTSELLING
HISTORY-1.
BUT, SHE STOLE 300 GRAND FROM
STORMING, I WONDER IF IT WAS AL
IN ONE SPIRIT THAT WAS TOO EASY.
WENT TO SOME LAWYERS FOR
COMMENT.
THE HEDGEHOG CENTIPEDE
APPARENTLY, PART OF HIS SENTENC
WILL BE SERVED CONCURRENTLY,
WHICH MEANS DONE AT THE SAME
TIME, KAT.
HOPEFULLY STORMY GAME HIM ADVIC
ON NOT TO DO THAT AT THE SAME
TIME.
>> THEY CALL THAT AIRTIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, KENNEDY.
THAT IS HOW YOU KNOW YOU ARE AS
LEAVES WHEN YOU HAVE TO SERVE A
SENTENCE WHILE YOU'RE ALREADY
SERVING IS SENTENCE FREIGHT IF
YOU REMEMBER AND I DON'T BECAUS
I SNORTED TOO MUCH RELIEF FACTOR
.
HE IS SERVING TO AND A HALF
YEARS FOR TRYING TO EXTORT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
SPORTSWEAR GIANT NIKE, WHEN HE
WAS HEARD COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
SENTENCE, THE JUDGE TOLD HIM
JUST DO IT I FEEL REALLY DIRTY.
IT SEEMS HEARTLESS STEALING
MONEY FROM A COMPANY LIKE THAT,
IT'S JUST NOT FAIR TO THE KIDS
WHO WORK 16 HOUR DAYS IN A
WINDOW LOVES BUILDING IN CHINA
SO THEY CAN CHARGE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS FOR LeBRON'S SHOE.
BUT HE STILL HAVEN'T SERVED 30
MONTHS OF A NEW SENTENCE AFTER
THAT.
WE WITNESSED STORMY FOR HER
REACTION.
>> THAT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S TH
BIRD.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK POST
THE ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY TOL
THE JUDGE ABOUT HOW DANIELS FEL
ABOUT THE BETRAYAL, YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE INCREDIBLE PERSONAL
BETRAYAL THAT HAPPENED WHEN SHE
FOUND OUT HER LAWYER NOT ONLY
STOLE HER MONEY, BUT LIED TO HE
OVER IN OVER AGAIN.
IMAGINE, BEING LIED TO OVER IN
OVER AGAIN, BUT IF LYING IS A
CRIME EXPECTED KLAXON ACTION
FROM EVERY DUDE WHO THOUGHT THE
STRIPPER REALLY LIKED IMPAIRED
STORMY DANIELS ISN'T EVEN HER
REAL NAME, SHE STOLE IT FROM
LOCAL WEATHERMAN IN DALLAS.
HER REAL NAME IS MONSOON
MCGILLICUDDY.
DURING THE SENTENCING, SHE TOLD
THE JOB I BROUGHT RIDICULE AND
EMBARRASSMENT EMBARRASSMENT UPO
MYSELF INCLUDING MY FAMILY, MY
CHILDREN, MY FRIENDS, IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION.
THAT IS REFUSED A LIAR, HE
DOESN'T HAVE FRIENDS IT'S IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO AS ANYBODY IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION.
WE HOPE STORMY FINDS PEACE
COMMISSION HAD A TRAGIC CASE OF
A FORMER PENTHOUSE PET OF THE
YEAR NOT REALIZING THEIR DREAMS
AFTER A PROMISING START AS A
FORMER PENTHOUSE PET OF THE YEAR
.
TALK ABOUT UNREALIZED
EXPECTATIONS.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK POSING
DOESN'T HELP IN YOUR CAREER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
DO SEE.
I KEPT MY CLOSE ON MOST OF MY
CAREER EXCEPT FOR THAT TIME AND
THE MID- 90s WHEN I DID THOSE
ART FILMS, ICAR THE ART FILMS
BECAUSE ART WAS THE ONLY ONE WH
WATCHED THEM.
HE ALSO SAID THIS TO THE JUDGE,
I DESTROYED MY CAREER, MY
RELATIONSHIPS, AND MY REPUTATION
, THERE IS SERIOUS
DOUBT IF I WILL RECOVER ANY
SEMBLANCE OF A NORMAL LIFE OR
PIECE.
YOU ARE SELLING YOURSELF SHORT,
IF YOU THINK BACK LIKE RAGING
CASE OF SPRING BREAK COLD SORES.
CNN REHIRED JEFFREY TOOBIN, THE
SHOULD GIVE YOU A LEGAL SHOW
WITH HIM THEY COULD CALL IT THE
RIPOFF IN THE LIKE.
REMEMBER ALL THE VANGIE MADE IN
MEDIA, I'M SURE THEY'LL BE THER
TO TO HELP YOU OUT, ONE OF THEM
WILL PICK YOU UP ON THE RELEASE
DAY.
MAY BE ON A BICYCLE BUILT FOR
TWO.
MAYBE HE WILL BRING A CAKE WITH
A FILE IN THAT.
MINUS THE CAKE.
BECAUSE HE PROBABLY ATE IT ON
THE WAY OVER.
IN THE CAR.
ALONE, YOU KNOW, JUST IN THE
FRONT SEAT.
CAKE ALL OVER THE SPEARING WELL.
CHOMPING AT IT, LICKING THE FILE
.
ALL ALTHOUGH IT LOOKS AND
CRANNIES.
WHERE AM I?
THE FLEETING NATURE OF LOVE VERY
.
>> WE ARE BACK WITH THE MAIN
PLAYER VERY.
>> TO ME YOU ARE LIKE THE HOLY
SPIRIT.
YOU ARE ALL PLACES AT ALL TIMES.
>> I THINK YOU'RE DOING I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE IN THIS FOR MONEY.
>> THE ONLY REASON I AM TAKING
THIS IS BECAUSE OF YOUR PRESENC
ON CABLE NEWS.
>> S.
IF I HAD A FULL POINT ISN'T TO
DANCE ON HIS MISFORTUNE ALTHOUG
IT'S PRETTY FUN, AND HE'D LIKE
TO DO IT TO US GIVEN THE CHANCE
FOR IT I'M REMINDING EVERYBODY,
THEY WILL ACCEPT ANY FILE
CREATURE INTO THEIR MIDST.
HARVEY WEINSTEIN SUPPORTED THE
RIGHT POLITICS.
HE DANCED TO THE TEAM THEY
WANTED HIM TO PLAY.
IT'S ALSO HARD TO BE SYMPATHETI
TO STORMY DANIELS, IF SHE WAS
PAID 130 DOWLAND AND HUSH MONEY
SHE HAD WHY DIDN'T SHE HUNCHED,
THAT IS THE GOLDEN ROLE, IT'S
NOT JUST LIKE TO SHUT UP WHEN
YOU'RE DONE UNLESS YOU TALK
DIRTY AFTERWARDS, BUT THAT SEEM
BACKWARD.
>> WHY DID I NOT.
I JUST NODDED.
>> THE AUDIENCE KNEW BETTER THA
TO LAUGH AT THAT ONE.
BILL LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT HE MEANS.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF TALKING?
PERSONALLY I DON'T CARE IF YOU
STEP AS A BILLIONAIRE FOR QUEENS
, YOUR REQUIRED TO
SLEEPLESS STIFF STRIPPERS, IT
SAYS SO ON THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
.
AS THE JUDGE IMPOSES A SENTENCE
ON AVENATTI, RUMOR EVERY DAY TH
MEDIA PUTS SENTENCE ON YOUR.
YOU ARE DOING HARD TIME, AND
DURING THEIR PHONY NARRATIVE
STARTING MISCREANTS UNTIL IT
FINALLY BLOWS UP IN THEIR OVER
MADE UP FACES.
AVENATTI TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
STORMY BUT THAT MEDIA TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF YOU.
HE IS IN JAIL, BUT THE MEDIA
ROCKS ON, WHEN THE ONLY TV
SCREENS THEY SHOULD BE ON ARE
THE ONES THAT MONITOR THEIR
SELVES.
TICKET LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GETS, SHE IS KNOWN FOR THOSE
GLASSES, THE POSITIVE KENNEDY,
KENNEDY.
HE IS THE FIRST OF MANY TO SAY
THANK GOD I'M NOT JOE DEVITO,
COMEDIENNE JOE DEROSA.
SHE IS LIKE AN ORANGE CIRCUS
PEANUTS, SOFT AT FIRST, BUT
CRUNCHY AFTER A NIGHT OUT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT, TIMPF.
FINALLY, HIS PAPERWEIGHT, MATE
MASSIVE SIDEKICK, BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK JUST TYRUS,
THE BOOK BEFORE THE FOREST.
TYRUS.
NOW BEFORE WE GET TO THE NEWS I
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT HERE WHICH IS
BEAUTIFUL SANDWICHES GREATLY GE
THIS, JOE, I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU.
YOU DID REDEYE AND THEN YOU
BECAME A BIG TV STAR.
>> REALLY?
>> I SAW YOU ON BREAKING BAD.
MY CHARACTER WASN'T IN BREAKING
BAD 50 THANK YOU, GREG, AT LEAS
PRETEND YOU READ UP.
>> INSIDE OUT.
SO YOU OPENED A SANDWICH SHOP O
THE LOWER EAST SIDE PRICKLY I
OPENED ARE AND SEE MY CHOP,
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
>> SMART MOVE.
>> YEAH.
THE WORLD WAS CRUMBLING AND I
PANICKED.
>> ARE THESE MAINLY SUBS?
GET THE ONLY FOOD WE SERVE OUR
HOKIES OR SUBS, WITH EVERY WANT
TO CALL THEM.
>> DO PEOPLE EVER GO IN THERE
AND JUST TAKE PICTURES OF YOU
THINKING YOU ARE JERROD?
>> I'M THE GOOD JERROD.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A T-SHIRT
COMING OUT THAT SAYS OUR
SPOKESPERSON ISN'T AN PRISON.
IT WILL BE AVAILABLE VERY SOON.
>> I WOULD EAT ONE OF THESE, BU
I WILL WAIT TO THE BREAK.
SPEAKING OF PRISON, WHAT YOU
MAKE OF THIS WHOLE AVENATTI
THING.
I THINK I'M THE ONLY ONE
COVERING THIS BECAUSE EVERYBODY
ELSE WANTED TO MOVE ON PRICKLY
FIND IT FASCINATING THAT HE'S
DEALING BOOK MONEY HE'S SUCH A
NUMB NUTS HE CAN'T GET HIS OWN
BOOK DEAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT ELSE
THIS GUY NEEDS TO DO GREAT HE'S
A CELEBRITY LAWYER HE'S TANGLED
WITH THE MOST INFAMOUS PRESIDEN
IN HISTORY, I DON'T KNOW WHERE
HIS BOOK DEAL IS, BUT WHAT IS
MORE FASCINATING TO ME IS THE
GRADE, A GUY COMPLICATING HIS
OWN LIFE YOU'RE ALREADY A LAWYER
, ON TOP OF THAT YOU'RE A
CELEBRITY LAWYER, AND THAT STIL
NOT ENOUGH.
FREE MONEY FOR THEM, HE'S THEN
GOT TO STEAL MONEY WHICH WOULD
BE LIKE ME BEING LUCKY ENOUGH T
OPEN MY OWN SANDWICH SHOP,.
>> AND THEN YOU HEAR HIM
STEALING COLD CUTS FROM SUBWAY.
EXCELLENT ANALOGY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS, HE WAS
LIVING BEYOND HIS MEANS.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS, IT'S ALWAYS
IS IF YOU MAKE A HALF-MILLION
THEN YOU THINK YOU CAN SPEND A
HALF MILLION COMING AND NO?
TO GET YOUR ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
AND THEN PEOPLE LIKE THIS HE
SUCH A JUST WANTS TO FLEX
EVERYTHING SO HE HAS TO HAVE
THAT LAMBORGHINI AND THE GUCCI
TRACKSUIT AND HE'S GOT TO HAVE
EVERYTHING SO IT REQUIRES A
PONZI SCHEME TO SUPPORT HIS
LIFESTYLE BECAUSE THE
HALF-MILLION DOLLARS, HE'S NOT
GOING TO LIVE COMFORTABLY IN
THOUSAND OAKS, HE WANTS TO LAND
IN WEST HOLLYWOOD OR BEVERLY
HILLS, AND HE'S JUST AN ABSOLUT
SUPERQUICK, BUT STILL THE MOST
VIABLE CANDIDATE THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE IN 2024.
>> I THINK THOUSAND OAKS, I
COUNTED IT.
TO GET ABOUT 400 OAKS.
>> SOLID 400.
THAT WAS A GOOD AFTERNOON,
WASN'T IT, TYRUS?
>> WHY ARE MY COSIGNING?
I KNOW IT'S FRIDAY,.
>> DO YOU THINK ANYTHING WILL
EVERY CAUSE OF MOMENTS OF SELF
REFLECTION FOR ANYBODY IN THOSE
CLIPS OR DO THEY PREFER TO JUST
WALK AWAY FROM IT.
>> WHAT IS SURPRISING TO ME IS
WHY IS STORMY DANIELS NOT SUING
CNN, WHY IS SHE NOT SUING
EVERYONE OF THOSE SUPPOSEDLY
LEGITIMATE JOURNALISTS WHO
DIDN'T DO ANY BACKGROUND CHECK
ON THE GUYS THEY WERE ANOINTING
THE MOST TRUSTWORTHY, HE WAS
QUOTE THE HOLY SPIRIT, ED SOUGH
THAT POINT HE HAD MADE GOD
STATUS?
AND HE'S LYING TO YOU, AND
EVERYTHING YOU SEE ON TV ABOUT
THESE JOURNALISTS IS THAT HE'S
HONEST AND FORTHRIGHT?
WHY ARE YOU NOT SUING CNN?
I'M NOT A LAWYER, BUT I THINK I
COULD MAKE THAT ARGUMENT IN
COURT.
>> THANKS TO AVENATTI SHE CAN'T
AFFORD ANOTHER BOY OR BRIT.
>> THE LAST GUY WHO THEY LIED
ABOUT, DIDN'T THEY GIVE HIM
$125 MILLION?
>> DID THEY EVER SAY WHAT HE GOT
?
GET THAT WAS THE LOWBALL.
WAS LIKE I'M NOT A SCIENTIST,
I'M JUST A GUY WITH A LOT OF
MONEY FOR IT.
>> I CAN TELL YOU HOW MUCH MONE
I HAVE, I JUST SENT PANDA TO TH
MOON.
THAT'S NOT A EUPHEMISM GUY THE
WAY, BUT IT PROBABLY IS.
WHERE AM I, KAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> LAST WORD TO YOU, DO YOU
THINK HE HAS A COMEBACK IN HIS
FUTURE?
IT'S ONLY GOING TO BE A COUPLE
OF YEARS.
WILL HAVE ANOTHER BOOK DEAL,.
>> EMIN, IT'S JUST INCREDIBLE T
HAVE IT FALL THIS FAR.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT HAVING
HIM RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
NOW IN SOME STATES HE CAN'T EVE
VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
OF THE FELONY.
HE WAS CRYING ABOUT HOW HARD HI
LIFE IS.
I DON'T DOUBT THAT, BUT THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU GOT BUSTED DOING
FELONIES, LIKE YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN EASY TIME,
THAT'S WHY WE MAKE THEM FELONIE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
DO THESE THINGS.
I DON'T THINK HE'LL EVER HAVE A
COMEBACK NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
WHAT HE DID, BUT ALSO BECAUSE H
STILL SEES THIS AS BEING SOMEHO
NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT HE'S IN
PRISON, AND NOT THINKING ABOUT
WHAT HE DID TO OTHER PEOPLE, HE
HAS THIS WHOLE WHOLE VICTIM
MINDSET, IT'S LIKE YOU HAPPEN T
YOU.
>> BY THE WAY, THIS ISN'T THAT
HARD TIME.
HE'S GOING TO BE BACK, I MEAN
IT'S TOO BAD THERE ISN'T THAT
NEW APPRENTICE BECAUSE HE WOULD
BE ON CELEBRITY APPRENTICE.
TAKE EE COULD HAVE THE DR. DRE
CELEBRITY REHAB BACK.
HE COULD GET ON THAT AND BE
VOTED OFF IN THE FIRST EPISODE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON CELEBRITY
REHAB NEVER MADE IT.
TO GET THAT SHOW A BODY COUNT.
>> HE TRIED TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
WERE TRULY SICK.
AND EVEN WITH ALL OF THAT THEY
STILL SUCCUMB TO THEIR ILLNESS